write a movie that you love that is why
do we go to see movies and you and
whereas movie just hits you in the heart
and you're like
oh my god that movie is great even if
it's pretty woman
how do you search for those beautiful
moments in the midst of tragedy
i think i find the tragedy first i think
the tragedy is what guts me and then and
then i try to
find meaning in the tragedy meaning in
my tragedies
and it's hard to find meaning in the
tragedy i've uh
i've
i mean since confessions of a teenage
jesus jerk i've written two other books
where i went even deeper into tragedies
and one i checked myself into a
outpatient hospital program because
i was suicidal so um
the
i've had to learn
to pick my tragedies
and then also um
and also give them time i think and
that's i wasn't giving my tragedies
enough time but
i the the the beauty of tragedy is
we're
we all have tragedies we all it's
we connect on it and i think um i think
as humans we we connect more
on
not just the tragedy but how we got out
of the tragedy like even in film even in
film it's like you put your character
into conflict then we want to know how
are they going to get out of the
conflict how are they getting out of
that little tragedy moment in scene and
then that's what
shows character building and i feel like
we're character building around each
other when we do have tragedies in our
lives when we can we find our ways to
pull out of it and then survive and then
go wait a second
okay how does this work for me
in um
you know in being with other people and
then other people it's it's you know
it's just um
the beauty of oh yeah i've been through
that you just you hear someone goes oh
yeah now i've been through that i get it
that's all you need and you're like ah
and
there's just instant camaraderie with
tragedy which is sad i don't know why we
need tragedy and we all just can't be
joyful buddhas but
for some odd reason tragedy
and
suffering i think is
in the theme of our lives and our
existence so
when we put it on the page um
then we get to see our protagonist
get into the tragedy get into the
conflict whatever the conflict is the
conflict could be
the protagonist wants to ask the woman
of his dreams out on a date you know or
it could be the protagonist is being
riddled by bullets and they're trying to
dive and they're in the trenches and as
far as the film is concerned and the
conflict's concerned the stakes are the
same
and as far as what the characters
um internal tragedy is happening
i i like to you even um
even when i have students who are
writing romantic comedies they apologize
for it i'm sorry i'm like don't
apologize and i was like watch mob
movies watch mob movies and and and as
you
look at the beats of the conflict of the
mob movies it's very simple because
there's a lot of hierarchy involved and
then bring it over to your romantic
comedy and you can add those beats in
and keep those stakes just as high as
the mob film
and but it's but it'll be under the
guise of a you know romantic comedy and
the greatest you know the the fun comedy
vibe a lot of it comes from a tragedy or
a tragic place and that's when it's even
more funny yeah so
that's great do you have
certain movies you recommend one
romantic comedy versus one mob movie oh
that would be yeah
i wish i had those um
i well i watched that tv series gamora
recently uh the italian i think it was
the italian one but as for mob movies
you know i'll tell them to watch i mean
i i you know i spoke ahead i don't have
i'm not a i don't have a good uh i don't
have a good knowledge of romantic
comedies or mob movies but
um one one movie i bring up a lot in
class and it drives
some people nuts is swingers um i think
that was 1996
with john favreau and vince vaughn
and
they're a group of friends and you know
john favreau's character his name is
mike and he's the protagonist and he's
trying to get over his girlfriend that
he's trying to get over heartbreak he's
trying to make it in la but mainly he's
trying to get over heartbreak and
everyone in the movie just wants to help
him get over heartbreak
but if you really watch the movie and
you watch the dialogue that's happening
they are fighting the whole time it's
almost like they're about to come to
blows with their dialogue but they all
want the same thing they just want mikey
to feel better mikey just get over your
girl your ex-girlfriend but
they're they're it's a constant push and
pull and it's funny and it's sad and
so when this when they're br when the
point of view of each character is
bringing in that high of stakes to the
same goal
that's when you know it's i mean if it's
it's it's a tragedy
to watch the movie the whole movie is a
tragedy but it's hilarious because
everyone's
the angle they're fighting at is just
funny sure sure i think there's some in
um
[Music]
moonlight and mystic pizza there's a lot
of dialogue that's very similar to that
too whether
it might be loving but they're yelling
and and sort of
it is like rapid fire with the dialogue
and yeah yeah that's and that's when
it's beautiful and that's when we
connect because we wait you know it's
like we want we want the character to
win you know it's like how is the
character going to win how are they
going to get there and then we almost
you know when when they're when there's
heavy conflict on the screen it's almost
like
they start to go into a situation we're
like no don't go there okay if you go
there you better do blank blank and
blank and of course they're not going to
do that because we want to keep the
movie going
another five minutes so it can't be
resolved yet they need to get more
sand in their eyeballs before they get
to the next scene so
why do you think your students feel they
have to apologize or some of them feel
they have to apologize for wanting to
write romantic comedies i don't know you
know it's
i think people apologize for genre
sometimes and and i'm just like
don't apologize it's uh
every story means something
um
no matter what you're doing and it's and
it's what you love you know just
was write the movies
that write a movie that you love that is
why do we go to see movies and you and
where's movie just hits you in the heart
and you're like
oh my god that movie is great even if
it's pretty woman
but if that's what gets you if that's
what stirs your soul there's a reason
for it write that right don't write that
movie but write write the um
[Music]
write the general idea and the general
theme in that movie right
uh you know write the meg ryan tom hanks
movie it's
it's all just it's i think
maybe there's a um
there's a pressure for like oh is it
oscar-worthy oh with this this would
meryl streep be cast in this and it's
just like
no write write your truth write what's
important to you
and that's going to make the best movie
that you can make now you know never
write towards something that
you just feel like is a good idea you
know that's uh that everyone's on and on
about
remember the movie foxes
i don't oh okay it has scott baio jody
foster
sally kellerman and is uh from the
runaways sherry curie oh my god
okay so and it's it's a and it's the one
of these movies where it just doesn't
leave you and so it's one of these
things where you would say it and people
go oh you like that movie but there
shouldn't be anything wrong with liking
a movie
yes it calls to you i totally agree and
i don't like it when people uh dirt on
other people for liking something right
that just irks me to no end and i and i
think that doesn't lead to more
conversation that leads to a stop
and so
you know if
it doesn't matter what people like it's
fun it's as
it's you know don't it's like you know
and i come from the music a college
radio music dj which was the snotty is
the snottiest in the 1990s and i was
that jerk and like so they started to
realize wait just because someone
doesn't know sonic youth or the
acoustics doesn't mean that they're
inferior humans um you know or maybe
they don't like a certain thing like
even the you know it's
if they don't like something it's fun to
find out why
that's the that's the why don't you like
that or why do you like that wait you
know i i found a i found a backstreet
boys song
for a project i was working on and i'm
like this is perfect
and i you know i know everyone's there's
gonna be a lot of people that are going
why is tony putting a backstreet boys
song in there
but um
but it's just like
it's just perfect and if someone wants
to go see the backstreet boys
just let them let them enjoy their
experience i don't like it when people
try to crush people's experiences
if they want to see meg ryan and tom
hanks
possibly get together
great why why do you like that movie
that's that's that we should be
passionate
about it because every life's hard
enough as it is so
you know um taking a crap on people's
taste is kind of the last thing we need
to do let's try to find out why they
like a certain thing that's where the
fun stories are as far as i'm concerned
yeah i agree i agree i think people
should whether it's music or books or
or film yeah
you should be entitled to if we want to
watch a real cheesy movie and enjoy it
and or even have it playing in the
background all the time there's
something that calls to us i use ocean's
11 a lot in my uh this is the solderberg
uh
i always say his name wrong up i said it
right that time uh his his remake
um but that movie's gorgeous as far as a
heist movie
and all the elements of storytelling and
i actually i'll watch it for fun
sometimes and people kind of are just
like you know it's like oh yeah well
that top 40 movie what are you talking
about and i'm like no there's actually
there's a lot of great scenes in there
that i'll bring to class and show the
dynamics of and just the dialogue and
the dialogue is tight and those actors
are all top-notch actors
yeah some of them are superstars that's
fine but they are great at what they do
and there's a reason why
most of them are superstars it's because
they've worked really hard to get there